Hello everybody. I hope that you're
good. It's happening. This projection is
so far playing out. Uh we were in the
second part of the projection. I would
say that we've gone through the most
critical phase of this projection and
now it seems that it's likely going to
fully play out. So we're going to go
through what I think is going to happen
next. We're going to go through my
thought process of this analysis. And
this is basically my first projection of
2026.
Well, not really because I've been
carrying this prediction since December.
So, it's from last year. But what I want
to say is that it's a great way to start
the year. I'm officially in a trade. I
didn't trade this move here. And I'm
going to explain to you to you why. But
basically, I'm going to tell you my
levels. Okay? We are in a range. This is
the local resistance and the local
support. You can see very clearly how
those also uh we could say that those
are the range highs and the range lows
of this tight area of price action. And
then above it we have a high time frame
resistance which is 100k psychological
level where you've seen previously price
you know reacting to to that level but
again it's a psychological level. So
it's very normal and that's going to be
a high time frame resistance. And then
we have the local low which symbolizes
the long week that we have here in the
daily time frame which I believe is
going to get filled because more than
90% of them do get filled sooner or
later. So we have this rectangle here
this box as a target zone that is
basically the 50% of the week that's
around 83k towards the 100% of the of
the week which is 80k. All right. So uh
that's basically my levels and then what
we were expecting or what we were
projecting to happen is that if price is
likely going to fill this long week
because it's an imbalance and it's the
biggest imbalance that I can see in the
chart. So if price needs to go there in
order to then recover without having to
worry about this area. So it could be a
real recovery then price is likely going
to do a liquidity run first because
that's the way that the market behaves.
And we're going to go also later to uh
2019 when there is a similar price
action almost identical and so far it's
been exactly the same. Okay. So we have
to the upside a liquid rune and a liquid
rune what it is essentially is a force
move in a fake direction in the opposite
direction in order to two things hit a
stop- losses and liquidations of the
right direction of the trade. So those
guys don't make money because when those
guys make money, where are they taking
those profits from? From the exchange.
All right? So you guys know that I think
that there is a lot of manipulation
between exchanges and market makers to
not let traders make money because those
are the real players. You know what I
mean? So they have the ability and the
access to to huge amounts of volume that
they can play against us. Okay? And
there is a thing that never changes and
that's human psychology. So when traders
see a range with a with a range high
resistance, very strong resistance and
then you see a breakout like this,
people think this a breakout. People are
longing here, this retest expecting
price to go higher. Okay, so imagine the
amount of longs that were open in this
zone and that now have been either uh
stopped or liquidated. Okay, but also
you have to imagine guys that any person
that was trading towards the long week
and it was opening shorts at the range
highs with this pump above the range
highs, it got stopped stopped out
because they have their stop losses
right above resistance. That's the way
traders trade. And that is something
that I'm trying uh to change myself.
That is the way that we trade. I think
it's time that that we notice how the
markets really behave that it's a big
player taking money from smaller players
and it's based on human behavior. Okay.
So, um the my way is you know I'm
expecting a liquidity to run and then
I'm not opening longs here. What I'm
doing instead is waiting for either
price to break past these resistances.
Here is where I will be open my longs
because 100K will be a level where a lot
of buy orders from also institutions
will be coming in and they will be held
in price above it. Okay. The same as it
happened previously until we break out
after testing at support three four
times. Okay. or what I was expecting and
this was my main scenario is that this
was allocated to room because price need
to go to this long week and for that to
execute that trade I need to see price
going back into the range when that
happens to misconfirming that that was a
deviation that was a liquidity run we
are back trading inside the range and if
we are trading the range and we are
range highs the most likely scenario is
that price goes back to the range lows
so that's where I open my shorts and
that's what I said the other day in my
last video. I set my two triggers very
clearly. It was basically this what I
said and also I updated you on my
telegram channel with a voice note um
telling you to be cautious about this
move. Telling you cautious that this is
likely not going to be a breakout. And
if it is then we need to see price above
100K. And I told you also that my most
likely scenario was price to drop back
inside the range where I'll be opening
shorts. Okay. and not sooner for the
risk of trading against momentum because
at this point you didn't know if this
was a breakout or a liquidity run. Okay,
for that you need confirmation. By the
way, I also want to tell you down in the
description you're going to find a link
to my Telegram channel. So that's my
official link. You're going to find
official links always in the
descriptions of my videos on YouTube or
on my bio on X that which is my link
tree. Those are all my official links
because there are a lot of fake channels
with even more members than my real
channel because they pay bots to make it
look bigger. Okay? So, be careful with
that. Those guys are are going to try to
scam you with fake VIP memberships
charging you $100,000. So, they're not
they're not going to give you any
content. They're going to scam you. So,
make sure to follow always the official
links I provide. Okay? Uh careful with
that. And basically what I do think that
it's going to happen now essentially is
that you know if price is trading back
inside the range it's likely going to go
to the range lows. It's a fact. And if
it's going to go to the range lows in
this area then might as well drop an
extra 2% one 2% to fill at least the 50%
of this long week. Basically what I
think is that I think we're going to
trade into this box. That's the most
likely scenario. And then at this level
when we are in this box here is what
I'll be looking for either a real
reversal which I would be expecting
maybe price to even sweep these lows.
That's why the box is a bit below the
local low because I'm giving a space for
a potential sweep of the lows. So if
price does a sweep of the lows and
recovers the local low, that's what I'll
be attempting to long again. Okay? And
I'd be looking to trade back inside the
range once again towards the range size,
the local resistance. But you have to be
cautious
because let me put you in the weekly
time frame and I'm going to explain it
to you here better. You have to be
cautious because if price drops below
this local low and consolidates a bit
here for a few days is telling you that
this area here this consolidation is
lost and price is going to find
continuation towards 74k where at this
level I'll be clearly expecting and this
is to me my most bearish scenario. I
don't see price going any lower than
this. What are we expecting here is a
sweep of the lows and then reversal back
to the highs because that's what
happened to Nvidia.
Okay, you can see here exactly how it
happened.
Sweep of the lows, reversal back up.
Okay, if you go to Google, you're going
to see the same. You're going to see the
same here. Okay, sweep of those lows and
price goes up. All right. And if you go
to I don't know if Netflix did it too.
If you go to Netflix also did it here.
Okay, if you go to Netflix, you can see
that sweep of the lows and then price
goes and runs to new highs. So that'll
be expecting exactly for Bitcoin. Okay,
let me put this one and let's go back to
the daily time frame and I'm going to
take you to 2019. It's exactly here I
have it marked.
Let me go there. You're going to see
exactly the same price, the same price
action. Okay?
You're going to see the liquid rune that
we talked about liquidity rune deviation
above the range highs drop which is a
big red candle. That's what I'm
expecting follow by a big green candle
recovery. Okay, that's what I'm
essentially expecting. Then from here
price dropped again. I don't know what
will happen there. Again, if price finds
consolidation below this area, then it's
dropping lower. But if we see a straight
away some kind of recovery and price
gets back above this area, above these
lows, we are back in the train in the
range, that's a safe area to long
towards at least the range highs. Okay?
Potentially you could take some some of
the position here and let it and the
rest let it run higher where you could
take more profits there. Okay, look here
also if you notice there is a perfect
liquidity pool that is this one here and
that's exactly where price found a
reaction and dropped again. Okay, so
that's you can see that price always
trades towards imbalances towards
liquidity. And the last thing I want to
say, let's go back to the current price
action. And the last thing I want to say
is that to support the idea of this
liquidity rune, I don't know if you guys
remember, I was pointing out at the
liquidations at 96K.
Do you remember? Well, if you notice
price went to 97K and then dropped
basically hit all those liquidations. It
retested the weekly 50 resistance, got
rejected there after hitting all the
short liquidations. And now price is
basically attacking the long
liquidations. It's basically a way to
trade liquidity to liquidity. The
exchanges and market makers all they
want to do is to make money. So it's
normal that they are always going to go
for stop- losses and and liquidations.
And it's the way I've been always
trading for the past I don't know how
many years. And and and the results are
there. How is it possible that somebody
gets this projection right? If if those
ideas and that theory of the price and
the market has been extremely
manipulated, it's false. Obviously, then
it might have some truth. You know what
I mean? So now basically what we want to
do is we're going to go to high block
capital and we're going to look for
liquidations. We want to try to see if
there are short liquidations or long
liquidations. I'm expecting long
liquidations because the short
liquidations have already been hit and a
lot of longs have been open here between
97K and 95K. All right. So, let's have a
look at Hypo Capital. So, I'm in Hypo
Capital and what I see in the low time
frame is that when price was above 95K,
96K, there were a lot of liquidations,
long liquidations showing at 94K. Those
are basically from high leverage traders
opening longs with high leverage to
trade a breakout. Those guys were hit
also a 92k. You can see that that's a
liquidation cascade that happened really
quick that move and it was basically to
hit long liquidations. At the moment low
time frame we haven't given it time
enough time for no for new liquidations
to appear. But in high time frame we can
see that the liquidations are clearly to
the downside still. Okay. And you can
see that they are all concentrated in
this area here of 86K and price is
currently at 91K. So this is still quite
a drop until we hit all those long
liquidations which I would imagine that
they are next. Okay. So I would expect
over the next coming weeks or days there
is going to be volatility towards this
long liquidations. Okay. Now let's go
back to price. Going back to the price
action, price has already dropped from
the highs 6%. Okay, from here we're
expecting price to drop another 10%.
Okay, that is basically my projection.
Also, I want to show you something and
is that I don't know if you watch the
video that I was analyzing alcoins,
those were XRP and Solana. If we check
Solana, Solana, it's on its way to drop
from the range highs to the range lows
as we expected. Okay. And that would be
basically price dropping
13% which already has done almost 12%.
So we are basically there. Okay.
Basically this first part of the
projection has been completed. And the
second part that is a bounce from there
depends pretty much on Bitcoin whether
if he holds 80K or not. All right.
Obviously if 83K is lost this is going
to go much much lower. And for XRP we're
are basically in the same thing. We were
expecting XRP to drop sharply because
when XRP pumps aggressively compared to
the rest of the alcoin market, that is
usually a reversal sign for Bitcoin and
for the whole market. Don't ask me why.
I don't know, but it's something that
we've been noticing for years. Okay? And
that's why in in that video, if you go
back to that video of analyzing XRP and
Solana, you'll come across my idea of
price retracing at 20%. Which
essentially already has you can see that
right now we're only filling the week
that retested that level. All right. So
first part of the projection completed
since January 5th until January 20th. So
in two weeks we analyzed a 20% drop in
XRP. All right. So, today I'm going to
talk about Netflix in a voice note on
Telegram. So, feel free to join. I think
we're almost reaching 20,000 members.
So, that'll be a reason to to celebrate.
Thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you